if we were to take
10 kids
okay
and they go to two different schools
okay
and one school of thought we would never
do this test but i wonder what the
results for this would be
one school says devil exists and most of
you guys are most likely possessed
and says that to them over and over and
over again
in that school that they're going to
fast forward 10 years later 20 years
later to see what kind of life they live
then the other tank is to go to a
different school and the leader at that
place says
you're protected by god you guys are
meant to do something big with your life
god's going to use you to do something
very special with your life you're
protected everything's going to be all
right
work on yourself work on improving
yourself contribute to society
lead control your imagination fast
forward 20 years later
i wonder what the consequences of those
10 kids on each side is going to be
okay
one side how many of them are actually
going to believe there are ways to
society and maybe they're possessed or
maybe they're and then the other says no
i'm supposed to do something big with my
life because god's got my back i'm
destined i'm supposed to how that's
going to turn out now somebody may you
know trash that argument and say what
the hell are you talking about all i'm
saying is i believe there's a lot of
power
when people of influence
their words have more power from the
pulpit when they say things and
someone's standing in the audience and a
parent said that's the priest that's the
pastor i think sometimes people use that
power too much and they hurt people and
they hurt him permanently for a long
time and it messes them up
and that that that upsets me a lot a lot
it ups because i've seen this myself so
for me
if i know there's power in imagination
if i know there's power in positive
words it's it's more
about trying to get that encouragement
for people to believe
you know
you have control of your life you can do
something with your life rather like
look at where america is at right now
what is america's biggest deal right now
and this has got nothing to do with what
you're doing but a part of it does
is
america is convinced that rich people
are bad people they're fully convinced
they're rich people are bad people
they're convinced when you say we gotta
tax the billionaires
do you know how many billionaires we
have in america seven hundred and seven
hundred and twenty billionaires in
america do you know what their total net
worth is
four point seven trillion dollars if you
tax them a hundred percent
that wouldn't even be anything close to
how much money they printed the last two
years six trillion dollars and you want
to tax the billionaires but because they
say so many times from the pulpit people
believe the problem in america is
billionaires so what if people from the
pulpit said
the problem is you and i got to do
something with our lives if you can walk
talk speak you speak a language you
understand people you feel
you have a healthy sense you your health
you have the ability to learn and
improve
you can change your life for the better
but that's not the messaging today the
messaging is victim victim victim victim
victims so for me
whatever the final product comes out of
a denomination or a church or a religion
is a byproduct of the leadership at the
top so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]